il faudrait arrêter de construire de
nouvelles centrales électriques gem
hydro va célébrer ses cinq ans on a pu
le voir une fois cette pièce de théâtre
mâle adulte sur deux plateformes bref
tenant au québec je pense à vue j'ai mis
deux roues et dans cette pièce là oui je
parlais d'hydroélectricité mais aussi le
pari de votre travail de comédien
ça vous tenterait pas de faire une pièce
de théâtre documentaire sur est ce que
les arts de la scène sont un service
essentiel oui vous un
bon sujet c'est vrai que ça fait un très
bon sujet vous êtes le premier et même
apporter ce mais ça serait vraiment un
bon sujet parce que c'est une très bonne
question à se poser moi je pense que
c'est les usa c'est la culture c'est
totalement je veux dire en ce moment il
nous manque ce lot et tous ces lieux le
qui vive dans une ville partout à
travers le québec où on questionne la
société où on brasse sd dernièrement
justement pour jamie d'euros 29 novembre
dernier j'ai rencontré sophie brochu la
nouvelle pdg d'hydro-québec s'est
elle-même d'entrée de jeu dans notre
entrevue qui m'a dit t'es les artistes
vous êtes toujours dix ans avant de
votre société allait commencer nos
entrevues comme ceux qui à dix et c'est
ce qui est merveilleux avec les artistes
les créateurs et vous nous obligez à
regarder en avant puis à réfléchir plus
loin qu est-ce qu on est parfois en
train de faire comme réflexion christine
beaulieu l'afrique je veux parler de
l'oeil du cyclone parce que vous aviez
remporté un prix gémeaux pour votre rôle
d'isabelle 39 ans mère célibataire de
trois enfants très peu tassé
indépendance est conscient d'être plus
concentrés les genoux la deuxième saison
débarque sur le site du point tv la
semaine prochaine le 3 février mais
comment vous l'avez utiliser ce
personnage là pour aussi bien le porter
à l'écran en fait moi je n'ai pas
d'enfant alors j'ai bien sûr observer
les fermes autour de moi qui ont des
enfants j'ai deux soeurs elles sont
jumelles elles ont chacune deux enfants
qui rassemble quoi examen
gagnon est à dire que vivre comme ça
avec leurs enfants elles ont foule de
plaisir aussi avec leurs enfants puis je
pense qu'ils avaient cessé si elle a le
choix allez dans une ville où reste avec
ses enfants écouter un film mais elle a
vraiment peu ce
film fait que
je me suis beaucoup inspiré mais ça
franchement les messages sont très
proches de moi donc disons qu isabelle
est un mélange
demi soeur de moi de toutes mes amies
femmes qui ont des enfants tu est
installée ici vous êtes soit chercheuse
ou très bonne parce que c'était aussi
excellent la série lâcher prise et vous
incarnez josiane qui est aussi une maman
qui subit de la charge mentale je me dis
comment vous voyez la charge mentale
chez la femme de 2022
fsss et on entend beaucoup parler d'eux
c'est qu'en fait les hommes son ensemble
sont présents là il faut pas non plus
les oubliés ou les mettre de côté mais
souvent mes amies femmes qui ont des
enfants qui ont une famille du team
foncia mais il veut aider mais parfois
les hommes ont pas le réflexe de penser
aux choses à l'avancé c'est normal en
fait les hommes et la femme on est on
est différent on a différentes forces
mettait dans toute la planification
l'organisation
c'est souvent ça souvent été dans la
cour des femmes de toute l'histoire de
l'humanité donc je pense quelque chose
de normal le puisqu'elle est aujourd'hui
on est en train de constater sur puis on
a besoin que ça change c'est autant les
hommes que les femmes ont besoin que ça
change parce que maintenant la femme est
travail aussi petits sets les choses ont
tellement évolué donc c'est un peu ça
aussi et le disque montre que t on il
faut faire des ports ensemble en société
à ce niveau là depuis votre sortie du
cégep de saint-hyacinthe en théâtre en
2003 vous avez joué dans 28 c l'italie
22 avril 19 pièces de théâtre qu'elle
expliquait comment fait le choix comment
vous faites pour continuer à ce rythme
là écoutez
ce soit du théâtre du cinéma ou de la
télé j'aime vraiment les trois millièmes
j'ai pas vraiment de préférence ça va
être l'équipe j'étais envie de me rendre
au travail pour collaborer avec telle ou
telle personne est ce que je me sentir
bien est-ce que
je vois
si je vais être confortable de
parce que les acteurs on joue beaucoup
avec notre qu'un
faux faut ouvrir le fouette c'est pour
jouer avec notre cas il faut qu'on soit
bien pour laisser la porte ouverte qui
si on n'est pas confortable et la porte
se ferme à pin up je pense pas qu'on va
performer aussi bien bref on dirait que
c'est ce qui est devenu important pour
moi c'est vraiment d'être bien pour être
capable de bien performer on dirait que
si j'suis pas confortable je sais que je
vais pas bien performé donc je dirais
vraiment les humains avec qui je
travaille maintenant s'est rendu ce qui
est plus important pendant la pandémie
vous n'avez pas chômé vous avez tourné
dans quatre films qu'on va pouvoir voir
en 2022 à christine goll et j'ai
l'impression que la prochaine année sera
encore là votre merci beaucoup merci à
vous merci beaucoup